schauen sie wir wollen natürlich erstmal
in möglichst alles daransetzen unter den
jetzigen bedingungen das
infektionsgeschehen in im zaum zu halten
wenn ich gesagt haben die zügel anziehen
dann meine ich damit dass eben auch sehr
konsequent die regeln einfach
durchgesetzt werden darauf achten die
menschen natürlich auch und ich bin da
sehr dankbar beim bußgelder verhängt
werden auch für das nicht tragen von
masken oder ähnlichem
das sind nicht anfassen bagatelldelikt
sondern das sind immer wieder ob
gefährden und mehr mit menschen und wir
wissen dass mit relativ mit einfachen
methoden die dinge die deshalb hat ihnen
gesagt diese frage ich komme aus einem
risikogebiet und ich muss in quarantäne
gehen die ist nicht eine kann-bestimmung
wenn ich gerade zeit hat sonst sein muss
wenn ich das nicht zur dann können
erhebliche bußgelder ausgesprochen
werden